LIKE TO CALL THE UTILITY ENERGY
COMMITTEE HEARING TO ORDER- I
NEED TO DISCOVER A FEW BASICS
BEFORE WE BEGAN THIS IS R.
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO
HEARING- WE WELCOME ALL OF YOU
TO OUR COMMITTEE HEARING FOR
UTILITY ENERGY. DUE TO THE
CONTINUED STAY AT HOME ORDER WE
ARE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCING HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE
TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WATCH AND PARTICIPATE IN
THE HEARING IN PERSON. WE'RE
ALSO REQUIRING THE MASK YOU
WARNING PHYSICALLY DISTANCE
PHYSICAL DISTANCE THEME BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING WEATHER
HERE IN THE ROOM. OR AT THE
VIDEO CONFERENCING SITE. YOU DO
NOT HAVE A MASK. WE CAN PROVIDE
ONE FOR YOU. BECAUSE OF OUR
SPACE LIMITATIONS WE HAVE SOME
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SITTING AT
THE DYESS AND OTHERS SITTING IN
THE FIRST FEW ROWS OF SEATS IN
THE AUDIENCE. FOR THOSE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK DURING THE
HEARING PLEASE APPROACH THE
MIKE BEHIND THE PLEXIGLASS
GLASS AND PLEASE REMEMBER TO
PRACTICE PHYSICAL DISTANCING.
WE HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS
FOR WITNESSES TO TESTIFY TODAY.
HOW THE PUBLIC OF ROOM.IF
YOU'RE A MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
HERE IN THE ROOM WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY ON A BILL PLEASE RAISE
YOUR HAND. I WILL ASK YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. YOU CAN EXIT
THE HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU ARE
DONE TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO
YOUR SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCING
UPON LIVING LEAVING THE CAPITAL
INCLUDING LIMITING THE ELEVATOR
USED TO ONE PERSON. AT A TIME.
IN ADDITION TO BEING ABLE TO
TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE HEARING
ROOM WE HAVE SOME BILL
WITNESSES MAKING USE OF ONE OF
OUR REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS
LOCATED ON CAPITOL GROUNDS AND
A FEW OTHER LOCATIONS
THROUGHOUT. THE STATE CAPITOL.
THOSE WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON
THE SCREEN. SO MEMBERS CAN
WATCH THE TESTIMONY LIVE FROM
OUTSIDE THE HEARING ROOM AND
ALSO ASK THEM QUESTIONS. DALLIN
WITNESSES WE WILL ALSO BE USING
MODERATOR TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGHOUT WHICH ANY WITNESS
CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE CALL
IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS
AREA CODE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN IN THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE
THREE. ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO
TWO TWO. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
UTILITIES AND ENERGY COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON YOUR
TELEVISION SCREEN. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO
AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOUR
TESTIFYING ON HIS BEGINNING
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
PLACE IN Q. BASED ON WHETHER
YOUR SUPPORT. OR OPPOSE THE
BILL. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN.
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE. THIS INCLUDES MUTING
YOUR LIVE STREAM BROADCAST. AND
YOUR SMART DEVICE TO REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTORTION. IF YOU HAVE
ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT AREA CODE NINE ONE
SIX. THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO
EIGHT THREE AND MY STAFF WILL
BE THERE TO TRY TO HELP. I ALSO
WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY.
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
WE AY NEED TO LIMIT HOW LONG
THE PHONE LINES ARE OPEN FOR
EACH BILL AS WE ARE ON A TIGHT
HEARING SCHEDULE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EGGMAN WILL NOT BE AT OUR
COMMITTEE HEARING TODAY AND WE
WILL NOT HAVE REPLACEMENT FOR
HER. WE HAVE TO MEASURES ON THE
AGENDA. AB EIGHT FORTY ONE HAS
NOT BEEN REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE. TESTIMONY IS LIMITED
TO FOUR MINUTES TOTAL FOR EACH
SIDE. ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
PLEASE BRIEFLY STATE YOUR NAME
POSITION AND AFFILIATION. WE
WILL NOW CALL THE ROLL.
FORECOURT. HOLDEN PRESIDENT
HOLDEN PRESENT PATTERSON
PATTERSON PRESIDENT BURKE BURKE
PRESIDENT CARILLO CARILLO
PRESENT CHEN CHEN PRESENT
CUNNINGHAM. EGGMAN CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA. MAYES
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI HERE WORK
HERE WORK HERE RAISE S. REYES
HERE SANTIAGO. TEN YOUR TANK
HERE SINCE WE HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU WE'RE PLEASED TO HAVE
OUR MAJORITY LEADER- CALDERON
HERE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE THIRTEEN ELECTRICAL
CORPORATIONS WILDFIRE AND UNDER
COLLECTION. SCHOLARLY HAVE THE
FLOOR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU MEMBERS COVER
NINETEEN IS IMPACTED ELECTRICAL
COST WE HAVE A MOTION IT'S BEEN
SECOND. I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN
I VOTE ON THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE YEAH WITH ME ON THE
LINE AS ADAM SMITH- WHO IS
WITHOUT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON IS HAPPY ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. MISTER SMITH YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU TO ALL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ADAM
SMITH T SEVEN CALIFORNIANS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB NINE ONE
THREE I'VE BEEN ASKED TO KEEP
MY COMMENTS SHORT AND I'M HAPPY%
TO OBLIGE WOULD JUST LIKE TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALLED ON
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE THERE IS DISCUSSION
NEEDS- TOPICS IS EXACTLY RIGHT
EIGHTY NINE THIRTEEN WILL HELP
OUR CUSTOMERS IN A TIME OF
ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY WE'RE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
RESPECTFULLY URGE. GUIDEBOOK
THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE TO
PUBLIC TO COMMENT OTHER ANY
WITNESSES. IN SUPPORT IN THE
BACK OF THE HEARING ROOM. C.
NINE. A LETTUCE AGO TO A REMOTE
TO. STATIONS ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES AT ONE OF THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINE THIRTEEN.
SAYING NONE. THE PHONE LINES
ARE NOW OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.OF AB
NINE THIRTEEN. MODERATOR CAN
YOU PROCEED WITH- ANYONE ONLINE
IS WHAT READY TO PROCEED WITHA
SUPPORT OF. WITNESS SUPPORT OF
COMMON. IF YOU ARE A PART OF
THIS BILL YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO. WE WILL GO TO LINE OF
SEVENTY FIVE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NO IT'S NOT TOOK A ONE SO
IF YOU ARE INTO PART OF THIS-
BILL YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO
NOW. THERE IS NOBODY IN
CHEMISTRY. THANK YOU WILL NOW
MOVE TO ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. I DON'T BELIEVE WE
HAVE ANY. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES HAD ONE OF THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS. HEARING
NONE PHONE MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES ON THE LINE THAT
WOULD WITH US WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. THANK
YOU FOR IN OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO NOW.
WHEN EUROPEAN OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL. WE HAVE NOBODY IN KILL.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM I WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL SAYING NONE WE HAVE NONE
OF WHO WERE ALSO- FOR REMOTE
TESTIMONY. A SO WE WILL MOVE TO
PHONE MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYONE ON THE LINE. WHO WOULD
LISTEN WISH TO SPEAK AS A
TWEENER. YOU MAY PRESS. ONE
ZERO. THERE IS NOBODY IN HUMAN
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE-
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
IS THERE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS THAT. MEMBERS HAVE
FOR. MISTER CALDERON. SAY NONE
OF CALDERON WE THANK YOU FOR-
PRESENTATION OF YOUR BILL WE
THINK THAT. IT'S A SMART TRYING
TO HIT THE RIGHT PARK PLACE
FIRST TIME I THINK YOU'VE BEEN
BEFORE COMMITTEE FIRST UNLESS
UNFORTUNATELY. WELL WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP. ALL RIGHT LET'S
CALL ROLL ON THE MOTION TO
DISMISS THIS IS GOING TO I'M
SORRY THE MOTION IS SET- THAT
SENATE AMENDMENTS TO BE
CONCURRED IN. OKAY RECALLING
THE MOST. HOLDEN HI HOLDEN HI
PATTERSON. PATTERSON HI BURKE
BURKE I CARILLO WELL I CHEN
CHEN I CUNNINGHAM. CRISTINA
GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA HI MAYES
MAYES I MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I
WORK HARD WORK I'M RAMOS RAMOS
I SANTIAGO. TEN TANG I. BILLS
UP THANK YOU MEMBERS. THREE
WHAT'S THAT OUR. WHAT'S THE
TIME I'M SORRY. TWELVE
REPUBLICANS DELIVER RELIEF OF
THE ROLE OPEN FOR MEMBERS TO
ADD ON- WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE
JOINED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA TO PRESENT A B. SIXTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN. SACRAMENTO. OKAY
WE'RE ON A ROLL HERE THANK YOU
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE AB SIXTEEN FIFTY SEVEN
ECONOMIC RECOVERY THAT FOCUSES
ON LITHIUM. OPPORTUNITIES NOT
JUST FOR CALIFORNIA BUT FOR
REGION THE NEEDS. TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF INVESTMENT FOR JOB
CREATION OUT IN THE SUN SEERY
RESPECT YES FOR APPLE. I
APPRECIATE THAT- IS THERE A
PRIMARY WITNESS THAT YOU HAVE
ON THIS YOU KNOW THE JOHN
WHITE. THE PARKING THING.
STOREWIDE YOU HAVE THE FLOOR IF
YOU'RE ONLINE. GOOD EVENING
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
TAKING MY TESTIMONY I'M JOHN
WILEY WITH THE CLEAN POWER
CAMPAIGN WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
SIXTEE FIFTY SEVEN BECAUSE WE
THINK THAT. LITHIUM EXTRACTION
FROM GEOTHERMAL IS GOING TO BE
A VERY IMPORTANT STRATEGIC
INDUSTRY FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS AN
IMPORTANT. ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
ENGINE FOR THE GOVERNMENT PART
OF CALIFORNIA PARTICULARLY
IMPERIAL COUNTY IN ADDITION-
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF
ENERGY ALONG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION OR
BOTH ACCORDING. EXTENSIVE AND
ACCELERATING RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT I THINK THE KEY TO
THE ADVISORY A BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION IS TO ENGAGE. STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS
TO GIVE AN ACTION PLAN SO THAT
WE CAN MAKE THIS HAPPEN AND. SO
WE WOULD ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS.
THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE TO
COMMENT IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM TO ADDRESS THIS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL SAYING
NINE. REMOTE TESTIMONY WE HAVE
NONE PHONE LINES ARE NOW OPEN
FOR ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN IST MODERATOR. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO NOW. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE UP BY SEVENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU KELLY
BOYD WITH THE CALIFORNIA LOW
CARBON FUEL AND ENERGY
COALITION IN SUPPORT OF AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY SEVEN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU AGAIN. AND
ONE MOMENT WE ARE GETTING LINE
NUMBERS. AND I'D LIKE TO FIND
WILL BE EIGHTY ONE. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING THIS IS
NOT POPPING IN ON BEHALF OF
ENERGY SOURCE MINERALS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. HE AND NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF EIGHTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS AT AND SHARE.
YOU KNOW WITH THE INTERROGATION
DISTRICT COURT OF AB FIFTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN THANK YOU. AND
THAT'LL CAROLINA OF EIGHTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AFTER GOING
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT. UNIGENITUS YOU
AREN'T SUPPORT OF THE BILL YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. THERE'S
NOBODY ELSE THINK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU REMOVED
OPPOSITION DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE BACK OF THE
HEARING ROOM TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NINE.
WITNESSES AT ONE OF THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS IN
OPPOSITION. SEE NON. PHONE
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES ON THE LINE THAT
WOULD LIST WHICH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. HE'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO NOW.
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL OF. ONE
ZERO. AND THERE'S NO ONE IN Q.
PROPOSITIONS. DO WE HAVE ANY
ONE ON THE LINE THAT WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK AS A TWEENER. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE TO ZERO YOU LIKE TO
SPEAK AT THE DEMEANOR. OKAY
THERE'S NO ONE LIKE YOU ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH JUST
COVERED ALL THE BASES THERE- SO
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE OR THE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. MEMBERS WE DO HAVE A
pAPPRECIATE YOUR- YOUR STRONG
STEADFAST- SUPPORT OF LOOKING
AT NEW TECHNOLOGY AND YOU'VE
GOT REALLY ONE OF THE- PREMIER.
DISTRICTS IN TERMS OF HAVING
THE OPPORTUNITY EXPLORE. OF
THESE NEW RESOURCES AND SO WE
APPRECIATE YOUR- MOVING INTO
THIS ARENA AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO. WORKING IN COLLABORATION
WITH YEARS AGO FOR. THANK YOU
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL OKAY
ROLL CALL ON THE MOTION. SHOULD
BE FOR THE BODY IS- THAT THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS TO BE
CONCURRED IN HOLDEN HI HOLDEN
HI PATTERSON PATTERSON FIVE
BURKE BURKE HI CARILLO. REAL
AYE CHAN. CHAN I CUNNINGHAM.
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
HI MAYES MAYES AYE MURATSUCHI
MERCI CHE I WORK LIVE WORK I
ADDRESS. REYES HI SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO AYE TANG TANG I.
THIRTEEN BOATS THE BILL IS OUT
CONGRATULATIONS. SO WHAT WE'LL
DO IS WE'LL GO BACK TO THE
FIRST. FIRST BILL FOR MEMBERS
TO ADD ON WERE NOT PRESENT AT.
AB NINE THIRTEEN MOTION IS A
SENATE AMENDMENTS TO BE
CONCURRED IN CUNNINGHAM.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I. WHAT
WHAT'S THE TOTAL OF THE VOTE
COUNT ON THAT. THIRTY THIRTEEN
THERE THIRTEEN FAVOR. SORE
MISSING ONE YEAH CUTTING
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM. THIS
MISTER CUNNINGHAM IS GOING TO
JOIN US HE HAS ABOUT TWO
MINUTES TO DO SO. OKAY LET'S-
FOR ADD ONS TO THE B. SIXTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN. GARCIA. CUNNINGHAM
IT'S- OVER OKAY. IF IT GETS ON
THE PHONE WOULD WORK. HOLD IT.
YEAH HE'S NOT COMMISSION OKAY
SO ON. SIXTEEN FIFTY SEVEN TWO
FOUR ONE. ALL REFERENCE.
THIRTEEN I'M SORRY LET ME DO
THIS- ON AB NINE THIRTEEN. WILL
WILL CALL IN THE FINAL ON THAT.
AS THIRTEEN THIRTEEN- AND
NOISES OKAY YES AND THEN
THIRTEEN I SAID. ON SIXTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN. AND NO NOS OKAY.
CERTIFICATES IS WHERE WE NEED
TO BE- WE ARE GOING TO ADJOURN
AS LONG AS WE'VE MADE CLEAR ON
HAD EVERYONE GIVE A CHANCE TO
ADD ON WHO'S GOING TO BE HERE
CUNNINGHAM WILL NOT. MEETING IS
ADJOURNED.